ايا وفي اجتماع وصف بالتاريخي عقد وزراء
خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي اجتماعا في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف هو الاول من نوعه
يعقد خارج دول الاتحاد وقال ممثل السياسه
الخارجيه الاتحاد جوزيب بوريل ان هذه
الحرب تشكل تهديدا وجوديا بالنسبه لدوله
ومن جانبه قال الرئيس الاوكران الاوكراني
ان الاجتماع ليس فقط مظهرا هاما للتضامن
مع اوكرانيا لكنه خطوه جديده ايضا لتعزيز
اوروبا معنا من زبروجيا مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام والياس فعلا هو اجتماع تاريخي
كونه يعقد في كيف ولكن ايضا من حيث توقيت
الرسائل التي وجهت فيه بالنظر لما كان
يشاع الايام الماضيه عن الدعم المستمر
لاوكرانيا من
عدمه بالفعل والاتحاد الاوروبي وكوريل
اعلن بان الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يدرس
امكانيه تخصيص ميزانيه تقدر بخمسه مليارات
يورو من اجل دع دعم الجهد الحربي العسكري
لاوكرانيا وتدريب نحو 40 الف جندي اوكراني
في هذه الحرب صحيح بان هذه هذا الاجتماع
هو غايه في الاهميه من حيث انه اجتماع
تاريخي يعقد لاول مره خارج حدود الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني قال
بانه صحيح بانه يعقد خارج حدود الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن هذا هو سيكون في داخل الحدود
المستقبليه للاتحاد الاوروبي بمعنى تطلعات
اوكرانيا للانضمام الى الاتحاد اهميه هذا
الاجتماع انه يحمل دعما منقطعا نظير
لاوكرانيا سياسيا وعسكريا ويحمل ايضا في
طياته تحديا واضحا لل روسيا الاتحاديه هذا
التحدي الذي عبرت عنه وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه حين قالت بان الاتحاد الاوروبي
سوف تتوسع حدوده من لشبونه في البرتغال
الى لوهانسك اي في اقليم الدنباس في شرقي
اوكرانيا وما جاء ايضا على لسان وزيره
خارجيه هولندا وغيرها من الوزراء الذين
قالوا ق بانه يجب تقديم روسيا الى المحكمه
الدوليه بتهم جرائم الحرب وتجديد العقوبات
الاقتصاديه عليها
وال الدعم منقطع النظير العسكري بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا لان اوكرانيا لا تدافع فقط عن
حريتها انما تدافع ايضا عن حريه اوروبا
ككل الرئيس زيلنسكي الرئيس الاوكراني حضر
هذا الاجتماع وقال بان الدعم الانتصار في
هذا الحرب هي فقط تتم بهذا الدعم الاوروبي
العسكري والسياسي وحدد ايضا بعض المطالب
من الاتحاد الاوروبي على راسها بطبيعه
الحال حاجه اوكرانيا للاسلحه وتحديدا
الاسلحه الدفاعيه التي التي تحمي المدن
وبالتالي ايضا دعم الجهود الاوكرانيه
وتطلعاتها للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكذلك الى حلف شمال الاطلسي وتوسيع دائره
الدول التي تدعم اي مؤتمر مستقبلي للسلام
من زبرج مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام شكرا
جزيلا لك الى